la parole est à monsieur le président
damien abad pour le groupe l'est
républicain pour 20 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
antoine de rivarol disciple de voltaire
jugeant l'aveuglément de la haute
noblesse de son temps disait ils sont
toujours en retard d'une année d'une
armée d'une idée monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez avec le président de
la république toujours un temps une
vision et une décision de retard il y a
un an nous étions confinés car il n'y
avait pas assez de masques et de tests
il y a quatre mois nous étions confinés
car la promesse d'augmenter le nombre de
lits de réanimation n'avaient pas été
tenues aujourd'hui nous sommes à nouveau
confinés par la vaccination est lente et
chaotique
vous nous aviez promis de vacciner matin
midi et soir
mais en vérité vous nous confiner 30 en
automne et hiver vous nous aviez promis
d'endiguer la première vague mais en
réalité vous ne fait que subir la
deuxième et encaisser la troisième vous
nous aviez promis des doses de vaccins
pour tous dès cet été mais en réalité
vous ne fait que gérer la pénurie de
doses disponibles en reculant toujours
plus cette campagne de vaccination de
masse vous nous aviez promis de gagner
du temps face au virus mais en réalité
vous avez perdu du temps et même du
terrain dans la bataille contre
l'épidémie
vous nous aviez promis de la clarté de
la cohérence de la constance
mais en réalité vous n'avez fait que
naviguer à vue entre arrogance confusion
et virements et revirements nous aviez
promis même la stratégie de la tortue
française dépensant le lièvre américains
britanniques ou israéliens partis trop
vite selon vous mais en réalité vous
êtes enfermé dans la stratégie de
l'escargot se classant péniblement à la
50e place du classement mondial de la
vaccination
vous nous avez promis la confiance dans
les vaccins
mais en réalité vous avez installé la
défiance le doute la suspicion sur le
vaccin astrazeneca
vous nous aviez promis un plan de
réouverture pour les cafés hôtels
restaurants lieux de culture mais en
réalité vous êtes contraints de
barricader et fermer à nouveau à double
tour vous nous avez même promis un
retour à la vie normale à l'été 2000 21
mais en réalité vous nous faites un
retour à la case départ
ce nouveau confinement dont vous
préférez d'ailleurs taire le nom
c'est un ter repetita symbole de
l'arrogance aveugle au sein de laquelle
votre gouvernement et le président de la
république se sont enfermés comme si
vous aviez si peu appris de vos erreurs
passées n'oublions pas que si nous avons
re confiné en octobre c'est parce que
vous avez été incapable de tenir votre
promesse d'augmenter le nombre de lits
de réanimation venise la santé prométhée
pourtant quatorze mille lits de
réanimation en mars dernier hier le
président de la république nous explique
que l'ambition est désormais ramenée à
sept mille lits en ans un objectif
diviser par deux quel aveu d'échec
quel constat d'impuissance pour
l'ensemble de votre gouvernement
et quelle souffrance pour l'ensemble de
nos patients et de nos soignants sur le
ministre de la santé
où sont passés les lits promis dites
nous la vérité la vérité c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de lits supplémentaires et dans
certains territoires le nombre de lits a
même baissé
la vérité c'est que notre système de
santé n'a soutenu compris de
déprogrammation massif d'opérations dont
nous allons hélas payé un lourd tribut
on estime par exemple qu'il y aurait 13
mille morts du cancer de plus à cause de
ces des programmations
la vérité c'est que vous avez été
débordé par cette épidémie
et pourtant cette pandémie épidémie elle
n'est pas éternelle et nous ne voulons
pas être condamnée en revivre à
permanence stop and go délétère les
français n'en peuvent plus de ce
sempiternel jeu confine jeu des confine
je reconfirme ce qu'ils veulent c'est en
finir avec cette crise sanitaire
malheureusement nous avons compris que
la sortie de crise ne sera pas possible
avant la fin de l'été alors il c'est
vrai il faut le reconnaître le président
de la république m'a
il a redit en même temps comme personne
ici il parvient même à nous annoncer
hier une sortie de crise sans calendrier
de sortie de crise
1re confinement sans confinement des
écoles fermées sans fermeture des écoles
et même une vaccination sa vaccin
permettez moi de vous dire qu'il ya
vraiment de quoi en perdre son latin
pourtant souvenez-vous le 1er mars
dernier le président de république
demandé aux français de tenir je cite
encore quatre à six semaines
quatre semaines plus tard il vient au
contraire d'annoncer de nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires et un troisième
confinement désormais pour sortir de
cette crise sanitaire
il va falloir assumer vos échecs combler
le fossé abyssal entre vos promesses et
la réalité est alors arrêtez de vous
défausser de vos propres responsabilités
refusé d'endosser la responsabilité de
ses propres échecs tout en imposant
toujours plus de sacrifices aux français
ce n'est plus acceptable parce que ce
n'est pas la faute des soignants mais
celle de gouvets du gouvernement s'ils
n'ont pas été capables d'augmenter nos
lits de réanimation
ce n'est pas la faute des français mais
votre propre responsabilité si nous
sommes incapables de réaliser une action
de masse dès aujourd'hui au fond les
français vous demande une seule chose
vacciner vacciner encore et vacciné
toujours alors c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'est ce que vous dites mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas ce que vous
faites
hier encore quelques heures avant les
annonces présidentielles
le préfet de police de paris annoncé une
baisse de 25% du nombre de vaccins
disponibles dans la capitale la semaine
prochaine
aujourd'hui encore monsieur le premier
ministre au moment où vous étiez en
train de vous exprimer ici à la tribune
et de vous gargariser de votre stratégie
vaccinale l'om un slot ms dénonce je
cite la lenteur inacceptable de la
vaccination en france et en europe
la vérité la vérité c'est que le virus
avance plus vite que la vaccination et
que sans vaccins suffisant
le confinement sera toujours une voie
sans issue votre stratégie de
vaccination
ce n'est plus un pari perdu c'est une
bérézina sanitaires jusqu'à maintenant
nous connaissions la stratégie du en
même temps
désormais nous découvrons la stratégie
du à contretemps permanent et force est
de constater que depuis le début vous
avez constamment un temps de retard
cette stratégie du contretemps permanent
elle a un coût sanitaire économique
social et humain
vous nous manquiez un monde plus agile
et plus disruptif et on vous découvre en
réalité prisonniers des lenteurs
bureaucratiques et des lourdeurs
administratives
tétanisée par les conséquences
potentielles de vos décisions
le président de la république nous
explique que nous sommes en guerre
mais il a laissé les soignants les
français totalement désarmé manque de
masques manque de tests de gants de
blues 2 / blues de lire et animations
manque de kits de séquençage est
désormais manque de vaccins alors oui
nous souhaitons que ce nouveau
confinement cerveau - à être utile qui
permettent de vacciner un maximum de
français et notamment ceux qui sont en
première ligne soignants bien sûr mais
aussi des enseignants et l'ensemble des
publics qui reçoivent du public comme le
demande
notre président christian jacob et comme
le préserve réclamé nicolas sarkozy nous
devons vacciner
eh oui matin midi et soir
la vaccination est notre seule porte de
sortie
c'est le seul moyen d'en finir avec ce
virus qui a endeuillé près de cent mille
familles françaises à qui je pense tout
particulièrement aujourd'hui et depuis
la fin du mois de janvier
ces vingt mille morts supplémentaires
c'est aussi bien sûr cette vaccination
le seul moyen de retrouver une vie
normale de tourner la page de cette
crise sanitaire qui éreinte les
soignants qui angoissent ces familles
qui inquiète les parents pour l'avenir
de leurs enfants qui met à mal notre
économie et qui minent le moral des
français
sans une action une vaccination réussi
ce sont les soignants à qui je veux
encore une fois rendre hommage ici qui
encaisse de plein fouet cette reprise de
l'épidémie
sans une vaccination réussi c'est
l'éducation de nos affronteront qui en
pâtit durement car ne nous y trompons
pas ce n'est pas seulement quinze jours
de fermeture de nos écoles collèges et
lycées
c'est malheureusement bien souvent une
année scolaire entière il s'en trouve
fragilisée sans une vaccination réussi
ce sont les restaurants les bars les
cinémas les boîtes de nuit les salles de
sport ils sont condamnés à rester
désespérément portes closes sans une
vaccination réussi ce sont les festivals
qui ne pourront pas se dire cet été et
c'est la vie sportive culturelle
associative de notre pays qui reste
durablement en travers hélas vous êtes
en train de rater complètement cette
vaccination des français
c'est une faillite sur les commandes sur
les acquisitions sur la production sur
l'acheminement sur la diffusion et même
sur l'exécution et comme cela ne
suffisait pas le président de la
république a décidé le 15 mars dernier
de suspendre le vaccin astrazeneca 24
heures avant la vie de l'om s 72 heures
avant celui de l'agencé européenne du
médicament en prenant une telle décision
de supprimer totalement prématurée vous
avez redonné du crédit aux antilles vax
est rompu la confiance des français dans
ce vaccin est bien sûr que c'est vrai et
chaque jour sur le terrain nous le
constatons nos médecins nos pharmaciens
n'osant fernier constate chaque jour des
annulations de rendez-vous vaccinaux un
peu partout
quand le nom astrazeneca est évoqué
d'ailleurs le président de la république
entretient un immense flou sur cette
avancée de la vaccination
il a inventé les rendez-vous vaccinaux
sandoz
dès lors comment vous croire quand vous
n'avez de cesse de nous annoncer une
énième accélération de la vaccination
comment vous croire quand vous nous
dites que nos voisins sont tous aussi
mauvais que nous dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
la grande-bretagne vaccine quatre fois
plus vite que nous
quarante pour cent de la population
anglaise a déjà reçu une première dose
de vaccin contre seulement 10% pour la
population française et elle a même
distribué des autotests aux enseignants
et aux élèves
contrairement nous en israël c'est 60%
de la population qui a déjà reçu sa
première dose
et un vent de liberté recommence à
souffler là bas alors que tous les
commerces bars restaurants salles de
sport et musées ont rouvert l'allemagne
bien que plus peuplée que nous pleurs
20000 mort du co vite de moins que nous
et pourtant la chancelière elle a eu le
courage de reconnaître ses erreurs et de
présenter ses excuses à la population
chez nous aucun mea culpa aucun doute
aucune excuse toujours de l'arrogance
est toujours de la fanfaronnade
cette arrogance elle nous a tant coûté
et pourtant depuis le début de la crise
nous avons fait systématiquement des
propositions toujours et encore
et vous allez voir vous n'allez pas être
déçus il est proposé dès le mois dès le
mois d'avril 2020 durée camion avec les
députés les républicains un dépistage
massif
vous nous avez dit à l'époque c'est
inutile avant d'entendre juin 2020 pour
multiplier les tests à grande échelle
deux mois de perdus en février dernier
nous demandions une harmonisation un
prolongement des vacances scolaires pour
ralentir la diffusion du virus dans les
classes vous venez simplement de le
proposer pour les vacances de pâques
là encore deux mois de perdu près de
3500 classes fermées du jour au
lendemain en raison de cas positifs des
textes et dès le mois d'avril 2020 avec
l'ensemble des députés
nous réclamions d'imposer le port du
masque obligatoire a minima dans les
transports publics et dans les lieux
clos
nous l'avons demandé dès le mois d'avril
2020 vous avez attendu le 20 juillet
trois mois de perdu trois mois de perdu
pour les français voilà nos propositions
et voilà vous retard par rapport à nos
propositions et continuons puisque vous
avez l'air dbsa continuons ensemble
pourquoi est-ce qu'en france que les
tests antigénique et les tests
salivaires ont mis le plus de temps à
être homologué
j'ai demandé avec notre groupe l'est
républicain
des tests salivaires par tous
dès le mois de décembre dernier vous
avez attendu mars pour les déployer dans
les écoles là encore trois mois de
perdus en janvier dernier nous avons
demandé des vaccinodromes à l'époque
notre pays'' la santé je disais au stylo
vaccinodromes avant que vous ne changez
dieu pied en courant en avril là encore
trois mois de perdus dès le mois d'avril
2020 nous demandions que les enseignants
et les élèves avec patrick et gsell
soient testées chaque semaine pour
éviter que le virus ne se propage à
l'école vous avez attendu janvier
dernier pour annoncer un protocole de
test à grande échelle dans nos écoles
neuf mois de perdu et dès le mois de
mars 2020 avec eric ciotti et l'ensemble
des députés les républicains nous
réclamions la fermeture des frontières
pendant des semaines vous nous avez
rétorqué que c'était impossible et que
le virus n'avait pas de passeport avant
finalement de faire marche arrière et
d'accéder à notre requête le 30 janvier
dernier seulement 10 mois de perdus
monsieur le troisième ministre dix mois
de trop
dis-moi de lassitude dis-moi
d'épuisement dix mois pour rien voilà si
vous aviez suivi nos propositions
la réalité que nous aurait pu affronter
cette crise sanitaire
vous dites vous êtes dans l'opposition
fait des propositions mais je vais
continuer en juin dernier on a fait une
proposition de loi ici même et vous avez
refusé de voter notre proposition de loi
qui consistait à geler les fermetures de
lits et de services hospitaliers pour au
moins un an
la vérité il faut qu il faut qu'on se
dise les choses franchement
la vérité c'est que vous n'avez jamais
voulu nous écouter même si parfois vous
avez été contraint de reprendre avec
retard certaines de nos propositions
autant autant je le dis autant votre
gestion économique de la crise est
satisfaisante et globalement efficace
autant attendait la chute autant autant
votre gestion sanitaire de la crise est
calamiteuse et poussive et à cette
gestion sanitaire à cette gestion
sanitaire chaotique monsieur le premier
ministre
n'ajoutons pas une crise démocratique je
vous ai entendu ce matin et nous le
disons clairement d'être l'ensemble des
députés les républicains la france ne
peut pas être le seul pays européen qui
mettrait sa démocratie entre parenthèses
alors maintenant le calendrier électoral
adaptons les modalités de vote et vivons
en démocratie
vivant avec le virus c'est une
responsabilité collective laquelle nous
devons bien entendu tous partagé
monsieur le président nous n'avons pas
vocation à endosser vos erreurs ni
validé cette gestion sanitaire
nous ne sommes pas comptable de vos
propres échecs sur les masques les tests
salivaires les lits de réanimation et
les vaccins alors vous ne demandez
aujourd'hui de voter sur des décisions
qui ont été prises hier
mais quel conseil municipal quel conseil
départemental et quel conseil régional
se permettrait de voter sur les
décisions qui ont déjà été adoptés qui
ont déjà été édictées voilà la réalité
la démocratie c'est la décision ici et
pas à côté parce que est donc très
clairement on ne participera pas cet
masque
à démocratique et à ce simulacre de
consultation pour une raison très simple
c'est que mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement n'en vous
déplaise
ici nous sommes le parlement et le
parlement ce n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement ni une assemblée de
commentateurs spectatrice de ce qui se
dit et se décide à l'elysée ici on est
là pour voter la loi pas pour adouber la
parole jupitérienne d'un oracle à la
nation ou d'un épidémiologiste suprême
et si vous voulez engager la
responsabilité de votre gouvernement
et bien si vous voulez engager cette
responsabilité posez nous la question de
confiance et utiliser la quartier 49 de
la constitution tels que la vème
république
bon le permet non c'est justement la
responsabilité la responsabilité du
gouvernement devant le parlement
le article 49 c'est le courage le 50-1
c'est l'armé des faibles c'est le
courage fuyons de gouvernement aux abois
et c'est la démocratie du vote inutile
puisque tout est déjà dans le marbre
rien ne changera que nous voterons pour
ou contre
rien ne changera aujourd'hui alors oui
donc ces conditions nous n'avons pas à
cautionner cette parodie de démocratie
tout le monde l'a compris ici mais je
crois que tout le monde est en train de
le comprendre à l'extérieur et que nous
sommes pas là pour valider vos échecs
successifs
nous sommes là pour proposer une
stratégie de vaccination clair efficace
et transparente
tout simplement pour donner aux français
un nouvel horizon et non pas un mirage
de plus comme nous l'avons entendu hier
et ce matin
alors oui en responsabilité nous ne
prendrons pas part au vote
en vous renvoyant avec l'ensemble des
oppositions à votre propre isolement et
en vous laissant assumer seule cette
bérézina sanitaire de votre politique
venant vous porter l'entière est
l'unique responsabilité
merci monsieur le président à bad
[Applaudissements]